[Müzik]
Herkese merhabalar ben Ayhan tarakçı
çocuk gelişimi uzmanı pedagog ve aynı
zamanda akademisyenim ama burada olma
sebebim bunlar değil Ben yeni Medya
içerisinde düzeni içerisinde bir dijital
içerik üreticisinin Daha doğrusu sizin
söylediğiniz şeklinde bir youtuber'ım
biraz heyecanlıyım Kusura bakmayın Ben
normalde kalabalık karşısında
konuşmaktan hiç rahatsız olmam Hatta
hoşuma bilgiler en güzel en yaygın Benim
mesleğim ama buraya gelirken Tabii ki
bir misyonla geldim konumuz Tutku Ben
insanlara tutkularıyla alakalı nasıl bir
motive edici konuşma yaparım diye
düşündüm Düşündüm taşındım işin içine
birazcık Klişe Hayat hikayemde
sokaraktan güzel bir şeyler yapmaya
çalıştım Umarım beğenirsiniz
dediğim gibi artık ben bir youtuberım
fakat dürüst olmak gerekirse bu kavramı
hala alışabilmiş değilim 7 yıldır bu işi
yapayım artık benim Ana mesleğim oldu
ama hala kendimi tamamen gibi bir
youtuber göremiyorum çünkü Benim hedefim
bir youtuber olmak değildi Ben her
çıktığım ortamda şunu söylerim ben bu
dünyada istemeyerek zorla youtuber olmuş
tek kişi olabilirdi inanın öyle planım
hiç yoktu benim beni zorla Takipçilerim
bu noktaya getirdim Sağ olsunlar Çok
teşekkür ederim
ama benim tutkum yayıncı olmak değil
yazmak da gerçekten de benim hayattaki
en büyük tutkum yazmaktır Hala da
yazıyorum kimseye okutmuyorum Ama bir
zamanlar bir Wordpress sayfam var ve
blog sayfam vardı ve Orada sürekli
yazıyordum kimsenin okumadığı bir
yazardım sadece yazan bir yazardım Altan
erkeklerin bir filmde çok güzel yazan
bir yazarım der
sadece Yazıyordu Ve kimse beni
okumuyordu ama umurumda değildi o dönem
Bu benim için çok önemliydi ben yazmayı
çok seviyordum o dönem başka bir anlamı
var çünkü yazarken gerçekten kendimi
daha özgür hissediyordum rahat
hissediyordum Çünkü çok zor bir dönemde
başladı benim akıl sağlığımın ciddi
anlamda zorlandığı bir dönemde başladım
Bu yüzden de yazmak beni hayatta tutan
kurtaran bir şeydi Şimdi nasıl böyle bir
melank konuya girdim diye soracak
olursak Şimdi burada hayat hikayesi
kısmına giriyorum ama merak etmeyin çok
kısa tutacağım
ben düzeyim buraya yakın Komşu sayılırız
Babam bir araba tamircisi Annem hiç
okula gitmemiş bir ev hanımıydı Ben de
bu ailenin üçüncü çocuğuydum işte bir
altı orta sınıf Ailesi köyden şehre
geçiş aşamasındaki bir aile doğal olarak
çocuklarla ilgili çok ciddi kariyer
endişeleri var Ben bu gelecek kaygıları
o kadar çok yoğurdum o kadar çok Maruz
kaldım ki anlatamam size başarılı bir
öğrenciydim karnemde her zaman yıldızda
pek iyiler gelir dedi takdirname alırdım
Ama takdir edilmezdim hep şu derlerdi
bana eğer kalırsan seni sanayiye veriyor
seni berberi veriyoruz böyle şaka falan
ciddi ciddi okuldan almakla tehdit
edildim Yıllar Boyunca bu korku o kadar
içimde yer etti ki benim ben üniversite
sınavında kazandıktan sonra çok iyi bir
derece elde ettim ve seçebileceğim
mesleğe iş garantisi en yüksek olan ne
vardı o zamanlar okullarını öğretmenliği
Onu yazdım Üniversitesine gittim
çok güzel bir 5 yıl geçirdim Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'nde gerçekten de hala
özlüyorum Keşke fırsatım olsa bir daha
gitsem
fırtına sonra başladı Çünkü ne zaman
Okul bittiğinde o diplomayı alıp hayatın
içine atıldığında gerçekten de gerçek
hayat beni tokat manyağı yaptı
diyebilirse gerçekten de beni mahvetti
bütün kendime olan inancım güvenim o
gözümdeki Işık 8-9 ayda yok oldu yıl
sonunda pestili çıkmış bir adam oldum
tek derdim işte hayatım geçindirecek
kadar para kazanmak işte ailenin eline
bakmamak için onu bunun ağız kokusunu
çekmek inanılmaz bir çöküntü
içerisindeydim inanılmazca başarısızlık
hissinin altında eziliyordum bu dönemde
işte yazmak beni gerçekten de ayakta
tutuyordum ben kendim böyle okyanusa
içinde mesajlara Şişeler atıyormuş gibi
hissediyorum ama hani biri bu şişeyi
bulur umuduyla değil hakikaten terapi
niyetine yazıyordum hiçbir beklentim
yoktu ama bir süre sonra tuhaf şeyler
olmaya başladı nasıl oldu bilmiyorum
Birileri bir yazılarımı bulmaya başladı
okumaya başladı insanlar beni işte Bilim
Teknoloji bu tarz konularıma kalbi biraz
felsefeye kaçan şeyler hafif bilim kurgu
tarzı ona göre takılıyorum böyle fanzın
tarzı
bir iki kişi oldu 5-10 kişi 20 30 50 100
500 derken benim bir anda o blog sayfası
site oldu siteden Forum oldu forumdan
YouTube şut derken şu anda böyle
karşınıza dikildin geldim
Hani Tutkun baştaydım yolculuğun beni
Götürdüğü Yer bambaşkaydı Fakat ben bu
Yolculuk sırasında başka bir şey daha
fark ettim bir yeteneğimi fark ettim
bunu Aslında ben yetenek değil de daha
çok süper gücüm olarak adlandırıp hep
böyle söylüyorum bu benim bir süper
gücüm benim süper gücüm var Nedir bu
peki süper güç anlatabilmek Ben bu
konuda gerçekten de Doğuştan yetenekli
olduğuma inanıyorum ve her zaman şunu
söylerim ben bu dünyada her şeyi herkese
anlatabilirim ben kuantum fiziğini 5
yaşındaki bir çocuğa da anlatabilirim 85
yaşındaki bir amcaya da teyzeyi de
anlatabilirim ve anlamalarını da Sağlı
Gerçekten bu alanda YouTube kariyerin
başladığı zaman iyi olduğunu fark ettim
bu büyük ihtimalle Doğuştan gelen bir
yetenek ama bir taraftan da öğretmen
olduğum için eğitimci olduğum için bir
anlatım pratiği diyalog pratiğimiz de
var elbette ben bu ikisini birleştirince
bugün Hani kariyerimi Merkez
noktasındaki bu YouTube'u bu noktaları
taşıyabildim ki başarılı olduğumda
görüyorum çünkü başarılı olmasam burada
ne işin var benim Demek ki başarılıyım
Peki ben buraya neden geldim ben size
Aslında bugün ilk başta ismi şuydu
hayatta kalma rehberi 4 maddelik rehber
Sonra dedim bu kadar karamsar olmam
tutkularınıza ulaşmak için takip
edebileceğiniz 4 yolda ismini çevirmeye
karar verdim önce isterseniz 1 maddeyle
başlayalım Hayat hikayemi bağlanma
noktası ile aynı maddi bir doğal
yeteneklerinizin olabildiğince erkenden
farkına Varın şimdi bakın hepimizin
hayatta ortalamadan daha iyi yaptığı
şeyler vardı daha başarılı olduğu şeyler
vardı Ben mesela dedim ki anlatabilmek
konuşmak kabiliyetim oturdu yaşlarında
keşfettim ve bunu hemen Yolumun önemli
bir silahı haline getirdim ve belli bir
başarıyı elde ettim Bu sadece benim için
değil herkes için geçerlidir gerçekten
de iyi olduğunuz şeyi olabildiğince
erken bir şekilde keşfedin ve onu
tutkularınızla amaçlarınızı
hedeflerinize birleştirip Çok etkili bir
enstrüman haline getirin işe yarıyor mu
Vallahi ben de işe yaradı Umarım size de
işe yarar birinci hızlı geçelim gelelim
ikinciye burada Bir Eğitimci olarak bir
itirafta bulunmak istiyorum özellikle
genç Arkadaşlar ben arkadaşlar biz
maalesef sizi okulda yeterince iyi
eğitmiyoruz size Aslında öğretmemiz
gereken her şeyi de öğretemiyoruz tamam
teknik bilgileri veriyoruz mesleki
bilgiler temel konular eyvallah Ama
çoğumuz size okul bittikten ve hayata
atıldıktan sonra ne ile
karşılaşacağınızı anlatmıyoruz belki
size yaptığımız en büyük kötülük bu
çünkü dışarıda bir dünya var o
diplomayla çıktığınız zaman size
Paramparça edecek bir dünya var bilimsel
olmayacağım Bu konuda dışarısı Savaş
Meydanı ve düşmanınız çok güçlü ve çok
acımasız
diplomayı aldıktan sonra o dünyayı
Adımızı attığınızda Bu gerçeği ya Baştan
kabul ediyorsunuz Beyaz Bayrak
çekiyorsunuz ve kaderinize razı
oluyorsunuz ya da Hayat sizi döve döve
döve öğretiyor başka bir kaçış yolunuz
yok mu ilk başta yok gibi ama bunu da
kırabilirsiniz bunun çıkış yolu da şu
savaş meydanına olabildiğince İyi
silahlanarak iyi taktiklerle çıkın
Mesela bir örnek Dediğim gibi ben Doğuş
Üniversitesi çocuk gelişimi bölümünde
dersler veriyordum ve Benim derslerim şu
şekilde geçerdim Ben önce kitapları
olduğunu anladım konular temel kavramlar
vesaire vesaire sonra da çocuklar bakın
kitapta bu böyle yazarım ama gerçek
dünyadaki karşılığı budur kitaptaki
öğrenci Veli profili budur Ama gerçek
dünyadaki budur onları
karşılaştıracakları şeylerle hazırlamaya
çalıştım ve sadece uyarmakta da
yetinmedim çünkü 15 yıl boyunca dayak
geliştirdim doğal olarak
Bildiğim her türlü başa çıkma tekniğini
öğrencilerime aktardım ki gayet de güzel
geri bildirim aldı öğrencilerim
geliyordu yanıma hocam hakikaten sizin
dediğiniz gibi veri ile karşılaştım
sizin dediğinizi söyledim bir anda onu
sevgilisi oldu verdim şöyle oldu böyle
oldu falan filan gerçekten de işe
yarıyor Yani özetle asla bir diplomaya
güvenerek hayat denen düşmanın karşısına
çıkmaya kalkmayın ağzınızı burnunuzu
kırar hiç gözünüzün yaşına bakmaz
gerçekten İnsaf beklemeyin
olabildiğince kendinizi doldurun gerçek
dünyada karşınıza çıkabilecek şekilde
bir şekilde öngörün önünüzden giden
insanları sorun hangisi sorunlarla
karşılaştırın hangi sıkıntılarla
karşılaştı bunları öğrenin ve bunlarla
başa çıkmanın da yolunu bir şekilde elde
edin ne kadar donanımlı düşmanınızın
kaçta çıkarsanız bu hayatta o kadar az
yararlanırsınız o kadar az kırılırsınız
iki dereden çıkarttığımız zaman
çıkarttığımıza göre 3'e gelelim Şimdi
bunu genelde hep söylüyorsunuz özellikle
mevcut Tüketim toplumunda hep söylenen
bir şey vardır istediğin her şeyi
başarırsın hayattaki bütün hedeflerine
ulaşabilirsin inanman yeter tamamiyle
odaklan güzeldir bence çok doğru bir şey
değil arkadaşlar
bir şeyi çok istiyor olmamız bir şey çok
seviyor olmamız bir şey çok tutkuyla
bağlı olmamız Onun da başarılı
olacağımızı garantisi değildir örnek
verelim Mesela diyelim ki şarkı
söylemeyi çok seviyorsunuz müziği çok
seviyorsun ama sesiniz Yok
karizmanız yok Güzel değilsiniz
yakışıklı değilsiniz o sahnedeki o ışığa
sahip değilsiniz ne kadar uğraşırsanız
uğraşın hayatınız buna ne kadar
adarsanız adayın bir şey çıkmayacak
olmayacak
bunu da erkenden kabullenmek lazım Sahip
olduğunuz şeyleri baştan görmek Bunu
kabullenmek lazım bunu nasıl yapacağız
peki birinci maddeye geri dönüyoruz
neydi birinci madde yeteneklerinizi
erkenden keşfedin
Hayal kurmak güzel hayallere ulaşmak
çabalamak zor ama hayalleri kurarken de
şu ayakların biraz yere basmasıyla lazım
elinizde olan şeylerle yolunuzu çizin
iyi yapabildiğiniz şeylerle öbür türlü
Hani biraz hayatı biraz Çikita Muz diye
gider Onu size baştan söyleyeyim Yani
bir süre gündemde kalırsınız Ondan sonra
uçağa gider her şey
Hayal kurmak güzel ama dediğim gibi
ayaklarımız biraz Yere sağlam basarsın
şimdi ilk 3 maddeyi aradan çıkarttık
geldik 4 numaraya Bu konuşmanın asıl can
alıcı noktasına ve Bence de Hayatın en
can alıcı noktasında şimdi dediğim o ilk
üç şeyi yaptık hakikaten yeteneklerimiz
keşfettik güzel çok güzel silahlandık
hayata karşı mücadele ettik O da güzel
Tamam yapabileceğimiz altını
doldurabileceğimiz hayallerin peşinden
gittik Eyvallah O da 10 numara E peki
bütün bunları kusursuz bir şekilde
yaptınız diye ne olacak peki bir anda
başarı kucağımıza mı düşecek Hayır Bakın
bu dünyada başarının ya da
başarısızlığın yaklaşık %80-85 civarı
tek bir şeye bakar
şans gerçekten şans o kadar belirleyici
bir şey ki siz ne yaparsanız yapın bir
yerden sonra şans yüzünüze gülmüyorsam
olacak Çok fazla bir şey yoktur mesela
Bakın size bir youtuber olduğum için
oradan bir örnek vereyim mesela
YouTube'da başarılı olmanın sırrı nedir
Sizce işte uygun etiketlendirme
sistemini kullanmak ve hiçbir işe
yaramaz çok aralarda geziyor Öyle şöyle
etiket koy Böyle koyuyorlar size onu
söyleyeyim işte Reklam vereyim işte konu
işte takipçi satın alayım gerçekten iş
yeremez işte Google trendleri kullanayım
analizlere göre içerik üreteyim güzeldir
ama o da hiçbir işe yaramaz YouTube'da
başarılı olup olmayacağınıza karar veren
şey kitlidir yani Sizsiniz Yani bizim
Kim Ünlü olacak kim kenara atılacak
bunun kararını siz veriyorsunuz ama
Sizde de şöyle bir sıkıntı var
siz yarın kimi yukarıya çıkartacağınızı
bilmiyorsunuz Yarın siz YouTube'da ya da
sosyal medyada televizyonda Neyi sevip
öne çıkartacağınızı bilmiyorsunuz Hiç
haberiniz yok ve doğal olarak geleceği
göremediğinize göre ve İnanın bana kimse
bu konuda herhangi bir kontrol ya da
öngörüye sahip değil elimizde hatalar
sadece sizin önceki davranışları
üzerinden çıkartılmış bazı sonuçlar ne
Biz içerik üreticileri ne Ajans
patronları ne YouTube'un kendisi Siz
kitlenin neyi seçeceğini neyi
izleyeceğini ne istediğini hiçbir
şekilde öngöremez burada tam anlamıyla
bir kaos var peki bu kaosun içinde ne
olup bitiyor derken ben kendi kafamda
bir tanım uydurdum daha sonra yazılım
dünyasından arakladığım din çaldığım
gibi tanımı sosyal medyaya uydurmaya
karar verdim Buna da dedim ki Algoritma
tanrıları Algoritma tavaların seni
seçmesi lazım Seni seçmesi lazım
gerçekten de siz ne kadar uğraşırsanız
uğraşın Günün Sonunda karar verecek
onlardır Algoritma tanrıları Mesela
diyelim ki bu dünyada kendi
istediklerinden bahsediyorum Şebnem
ferah'tan çok daha iyi işte Rock
şarkıları söyleyebilen bir sanatçı
vardır belki ya da belki Hüseyin
bolt'tan çok daha hızlı koşan birileri
vardır belki bir yerlerde Ayrıca
newton'u cebinden çıkartacak bir adam ya
da bir kadın vardır ama biz onların
hiçbirini bilmiyoruz Haberimiz Yok neden
Algoritma onları seçmedi aygır sizi
seçti
Bu iş biraz böyledir bakın dünya
Gerçekten bu kaosun içerisinde Her şey
bir anlam yükleyemiyoruz yani her yıl
okullardan binlerce öğrenci mezun oluyor
Mühendisler Doktorlar tiyatro oyuncuları
aktrisler aktörler sanatçılar şarkıcılar
ama günün sonunda bakıyorsunuz bir tane
yalan baskı var Allah'tan bir tane var
ikincisi gerçekten çekilmez bu dünyada
ya da bir tane fadimerkür var bir tane
Barış Manço var bir tane İlber Ortaylı
var ondan 2 tane olsa güzel olurdu ama
muhabbette dehşet olurdu düşünüyorum da
ya da işte bir tane Einstein var bir
tane Ayhan tarakçı var
neyin ne olacağına kim karar veriyor
dediğin gibi Algoritma tanıdın dediğimiz
bu kaosu benim anlamlandırma çabam
kabaca toparlayacak olursam Evet
Algoritma tanrıları gerçekten kimin
kazanacağına karar veriyor ama bu demek
değildir ki ben böyle durayım gelsin
beni görsün beni seçsin Öyle de bir şey
yok doğal olarak sizin bir adım atmanız
lazım Sizin bir hamle yapmanız lazım
Sizin bir kendinizi göstermeniz lazım
Hani tanrılara kendinizi bir gösterin
beğendirin Belki sizi seçerler o yüzden
şans deyince de direkt şansı güvenip de
kıpırtısız kalmayın Siz yine elinizden
geleni yapın ama Unutmayın ki son kararı
Algoritma tanrıları verecektir Bunun
bilincinde olun Neyse Son sözlerimi
söyleyeyim isterseniz konumuz tutku ve
gördüğünüz gibi benim ilk tutkum
yazmakta ve günün sonunda büyük bir
yazar olamadım hala yazıyorum ama
dediğim gibi eşimden başka kimseyi
okutmuyorum büyük bir yazarı olamadım
ama yeni Medya düzeninde kendime güzel
Saygın bir yer buldum halinden memnunum
Algoritma tanrıları beni seçici onları
çok teşekkür ediyorum kurban falan
vermeyeceğim ama teşekkür ediyorum
Umarım bu salonda da birçok kişiyi
Algoritma Tanrı seçer ve onlarda
başarılı olurlar çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]